anime des sessions de formation alors
premier point les effets pour la santé
des femmes des violences sexistes et
sexuelles ce que nous avons pu constater
sur les victimes c'est qu'il y a
effectivement à la fois des impacts
psychologiques et physiques en termes de
culpabilité d'anxiété de dépression
d'insomnie migraine de stress
d'addiction tentatives de suicide
également des impacts sur le travail au
niveau des victimes perte de confiance
dans ses compétences
isolement
absentéisme retard déconcentration avec
tous les risques de désinsertion de
mutation et de licenciements de rupture
conventionnelle éventuellement dans le
meilleur des cas
et puis des impacts bien sûr sur la vie
personnelle puisqu'il y a souvent s'il y
a un arrêt maladie trop long fin des
indemnités journalières au bout de trois
mois endettement difficulté avec
l'entourage qui se cumule rupture de vie
sociale il y a également des impacts sur
le collectif de travail sur les équipes
malaises des témoins ambiances de
travail dégradé tension clivage entre
les salariés
et puis bien sûr sur l'entreprise j'en
ai dit deux mots atteintes à l'image
avec le rôle des réseaux sociaux perte
de talent manque d'attractivité et puis
bien sûr risque de contentieux etc alors
le quart à ce sujet que je voulais vous
présenter c'est celui d'une agence
commerciale d'une entreprise
électronique internationale ce sont des
propos que je qui proviennent d'un
article de la revue des conditions de
travail numéro 13 aux éditions de La
nacte consacrée aux questions d'égalité
un article écrit par Sophie Bardou qui
est une psychologue du travail dans un
service de prévention et de santé au
travail et de Sophie Morel qui est
chargé de mission dans une à acte dans
la région
alors dans ce cas donc cette agence
commerciale d'une entreprise
son siège est par chaque région à sa
direction régionale et la salle riait
concernée donc victime travaille dans
l'une des 20 agences commerciales de la
région dans cette agence il y a cette
salariés mais elle est la seule femme
assistante avec six commerciaux sur le
site de l'agence on trouve également le
bureau des responsables des ressources
humaines la salarié le dépanne de temps
en temps la situation économique et
florissante les commerciaux sont très
valorisés l'ambiance interne est à la
compétition et à la surenchère
en fait c'est lors d'une visite médicale
donc auprès du médecin du travail après
plusieurs arrêts maladie que Madame V
s'effondre en pleurs elle explique
qu'elle ne dort plus n'a plus d'appétit
a perdu 10 kilos qu'elle souffre de
problèmes de mémoire de concentration
quelle sursaute fréquemment qu'elle
doute d'elle-même désormais de ses
compétences dans sa vie personnelle elle
est irritable néglige son apparence et
sa santé son couple est fragilisé elle
est totalement épuisée déclare un
diabète elle ne sait pas à qui en parler
malgré les menaces à peine déguisées du
RRH elle a tenté à plusieurs reprises
d'évoquer ça discrètement sa situation
au siège parisien mais personne ne
semble vouloir comprendre il lui
répondit nous avons pleinement confiance
en Monsieur B le RRH c'est un homme très
compétent sur qui l'on peut compter vous
êtes sûr que vous n'exagérez pas un peu
peut-être que vous êtes mal compris
essayez d'en parler avec lui
c'est un homme très ouvert avec un peu
de bonne volonté vous y arriverez elle
n'insiste pas car elle craint pour son
emploi sa carrière et conclut que cela
est vain le médecin du travail l'oriente
vers la psychologue du travail pour
qu'elle bénéficie d'un soutien moral et
qui puisse y voir plus clair dans cette
situation sa situation
il est question de réfléchir aux
conditions de sa reprise du train le
médecin du travail propose à la salarié
de se mettre en relation avec la
direction régionale mais elle ne préfère
pas craignant des représailles
finalement la perte des indemnités
journalières provoque un déclic et elle
prend conseil auprès de l'inspecteur du
travail d'un avocat qu'elle règle à ses
frais
la pression est mise sur l'entreprise
une enquête interne et menée
et finalement cette enquête conclut que
le RRH avait bien eu des propos des
agissements relevant du harcèlement
sexuel et du harcèlement le moral le RRH
et licencié de l'entreprise pour faute
grave les commerciaux reçoivent un
avertissement mais la salarié n'est pas
n'a pas porté plainte au pénal elle nous
dit j'ai besoin de tourner la page et de
toute façon je ne crois pas en la
justice pour ce genre de choses le RRH
n'a donc pas été condamné la salarié
pouvait reprendre son travail mais un
syndrome d'évitement persistant se
traduit par une incapacité à revenir sur
le site et à faire face à l'équipe elle
négocia un départ lui permettant de se
reconstruire en tant que femme et en
tant que professionnel
voilà cela termine mon premier point sur
le deuxième point quels sont les
facteurs du risque qu'elle causent dans
l'environnement de travail
quand il y a des cas ce que nous avons
constaté c'est que les entreprises
gardent comme clé de lecture que les
violences c'est une question de
comportement inapproprié et quelles sont
la conséquence de relation
inter-individuelles l'auteur ne pense
qu'à ça la victime elle l'a bien cherché
ce qui est vrai mais ce qui n'est pas
suffisant et comme on dit les
sociologues les violences sexistes
sexuelles sont aussi la conséquence de
certains environnements de travail de
certaines organisations de travail de
certains fonctionnements collectifs
et cela a été confirmé par des études de
l'adresse et nos propres enquêtes de
terrain intervention de terrain nous
avons fait le constat que certains
facteurs organisationnels
exposent plus certains secteurs certains
métiers certains postes que d'autres aux
violences alors au niveau des
organisations comme cela était dit c'est
certain environnement de travail peu
mixtes après dominance masculine mais
aussi féminine comme la mode ou la
petite enfance vis-à-vis des hommes
c'est aussi certaines organisations de
travail très hiérarchisées comme à
l'hôpital ou très peu hiérarchisé comme
dans le monde du spectacle ou des
startups c'est aussi certains postes de
travail très dépendants ou très peu
autonome ou reconnu assistant assistante
haute ou hôtesses d'accueil et vous
l'avez vu avec l'audition de Gabriel
Schwitz qui s'accompagne d'une
répartition sexuée sexiste des activités
de travail
avec une dévalorisation des activités
après dominance féminine ce sont aussi
comme cela était dit des conditions
d'emplois les statues précaires les
stagiaires les apprentis qui sont
surexposés dans le secteur de l'hôtel
restauration de la propreté de
l'événementiel du tourisme et au niveau
des conditions de travail ce sont
certaines conditions de travail le
travail de nuit le soir le travail isolé
le travail sous pression le travail avec
des tenues ou une scénographie sexuée et
puis bien sûr les métiers en relation
avec le public les usagers les clients
les bénéficiaires et je pense au service
à la personne
tu es d'ailleurs très significatif que
suite à la deuxième vague me too de 2021
le réseau anattarate a eu des demandes
de fédération sportive de secteurs de
l'événementiel du spectacle vivant et du
monde de l'enseignement supérieur
il y a ce sujet je ne peux recommander
le kit de prévention qui est à mon sens
le meilleur qui a été fait par en
collaboration avec le CHSCT de
l'audiovisuel et du cinéma et qui
mentionne de manière très explicite et
qui met en parallèle d'une part les
facteurs de risque et d'autre part les
mesures de prévention à mettre en place
en situation de tournage de films par
exemple
il mentionne très explicitement les
situations de travail isolé la précarité
des contrats de travail les rapports
sociaux dégradés entre collègues le
travail de nuit les déplacements le
travail en relation avec le public et
puis plus précisément le contexte de
travail avec une grande proximité
impliquant l'intimider il y a l'intimité
ou la nudité les situations d'emprise et
du pouvoir et bien sûr les situations
festives
situation de consommation de produits
désinhibants ou psychoactifs et si l'on
reprend mon cas précédent donc dans le
cadre de cette agence commerciale ce que
nous pouvons remarquer c'est que nous
retrouvons un certain nombre de facteurs
le premier est celui de manque de mixité
une seule femme effectivement avec cet
homme et puis c'est aussi la culture
viriliste commerciale de compétition
et c'est également concernant
l'organisation de l'activité de travail
cette dépendance de l'assistant
vis-à-vis des commerciaux qui ne
manquent pas de lui faire remarquer que
si elle a du travail ou un emploi c'est
grâce à eux
et puis c'est également cette culture
sexiste avec beaucoup de blagues à
connotation sexistes et sexuelle des
hommes qui se vendent de leur vie
sexuelle réelle ou fantasmée et qui
demande à cette
assistante beaucoup d'informations sur
sa propre vie sexuelle je vous passerai
l'ensemble des des verbatines et se
rajoute à cela
le
des tentatives régulières de la part de
ces commerciaux et du RRH pour tenter
leurs chances pour une relation sexuelle
il se permet d'héflements
et n'obtenons pas ce qu'il veut le RRH
finalement intensifie la pression en la
harcelant moralement et l'on constate
souvent ce cumul de harcèlement moral et
du harcèlement sexuel avec refus des
congés horaires modifié modifier
l'empêchant d'aller à des rendez-vous
médicaux reprochent ainsi
et puis le dernier facteur c'est
l'isolement sur le site avec les RRH
contre les commerciaux sont absents
celui-ci se permet de lui toucher les
fesses et les cuisses ce qui relève de
l'agression sexuelle quand j'allais à la
photocopieuse dit-elle il se collait à
moi et mettait ses mains dans les roches
et je vais substinctement vous présenter
un deuxième cas un cas dans un
restaurant un cas en fait dans une unité
de travail qui pour le coup in mixte il
y a 15 salariés
10 femmes et 5 hommes 10 CDI et 5
contrats d'apprentissage mais les postes
qualifiés à responsabilités sont celui
de chef de cuisine ou de chefs de rang
et sont pour les hommes et dans ce cas
là nous retrouvons un management très
paternaliste
sexiste et autoritaire de l'employeur
basé sur le divisé pour mieux régner
avec des réflexions du type
c'est encore en arrêt les filles vous
allez devoir vous sortir les doigts du
cul excusez-moi peut-être à ne pas
mettre dans la retranscription pour
faire son boulot ou bien dis donc les
deux là je ne veux plus vous voir
ensemble vous n'avez pas besoin de vous
raconter vos vies pour éplucher les
légumes si les mecs papotent comme des
gonzesses maintenant c'est encore c'est
toujours cette culture de l'entreprise
avec ce chef dans la toute-puissance
reproduisant des schémas anciens
j'ai toujours vu ça en cuisine il faut
que ça tourne c'est comme à l'armée il y
a un chef et les autres s'écrase ce sont
bien sûr des conditions d'emplois avec
des femmes en situation de précarité car
ils sont tout apprentis ou mère isolés
et c'est le harcèlement par chantage ou
pression et rendu d'autant plus facile
c'est aussi ces conditions de travail
avec horaires décalés ce qui limite
d'ailleurs le nombre de témoins des
locaux inadaptés avec dans les cuisines
beaucoup de promiscuités des zones
aveugles favorisant les rapprochements
et légitimement les contacts et puis
c'est l'exigence de tenue féminine près
du corps pour les femmes qui sont
serveuses car c'est bon pour le commerce
voilà alors mon troisième point sera sur
les mesures mises en place pour prévenir
les employeurs
même si les entreprises considèrent ce
sujet comme l'ont dit les sociologues
comme un sujet de prévention et non pas
un sujet égalité d'ailleurs prévention
en lien avec leur responsabilité en
matière de moyens et du résultat en
matière de santé psychique et mentale
les entreprises en fait ne se
préoccupent des violences sexistes et
sexuelles qu'à l'occasion soit du
traitement d'une alerte ou d'un
signalement de harcèlement sexuel par
exemple ou d'agressions sexuelle mais là
on agit après c'est ce qu'on appelle la
prévention tertiaire ou bien à
l'occasion de sensibilisation ou de
formation du personnel ce qu'on appelle
la prévention secondaire on forme pour
apprendre à reconnaître les situations à
risque ou signaler mais les entreprises
remonter très rarement à ce qu'on
appelle de la prévention primaire pour
limiter les facteurs du risque au niveau
des conditions de travail ou des
situations inégalitaires entre les
hommes
si je reprends le premier point
concernant la prévention tertiaire le
traitement d'une alerte ou d'un
signalement ce que l'on constate dans
les entreprises c'est qu'elle traite les
situations aujourd'hui au cas par cas
mais cela comporte beaucoup de limites
d'abord il y a une sous-décration énorme
des plaintes une sous-déclaration
car par crainte de représailles les
victimes n'osent pas dénoncer en interne
et les entreprises sont très réticentes
à externaliser le recueil des plaintes
par le biais de numéro dédié ou de
services extérieur ce que nous leur
recommandons
s'il y a dénonciation l'enquête là aussi
est menée trop souvent en interne or
c'est très compliqué de mettre en cause
un collègue encore plus un supérieur et
archiques un directeur ou une directrice
et c'est très difficile aussi de garder
la confidentialité or nous recommandons
aussi que l'enquête soit réalisée en
externe le troisième point très
compliqué c'est l'impunité des auteurs
qui fait que les victimes se disent à
quoi bon c'est ce qu'on a vu dans le cas
d'un reste du restaurant justement où
finalement le chef cuisinier inculpé
sera
finalement aura 10 jours de suspension
de de travail mais finalement
cela ne l'empêche pas de revenir dans le
restaurant
et finalement c'est l'apprenti qui est
parti et qui n'a pas pu reprendre le
travail il y a réellement un point dur
sur cette question d'impunité car les
entreprises n'osent pas m'y annoncer ni
inscrire dans leurs accords égalité
qu'elles vont sanctionner et du coup on
se retrouve encore trop dans des
situations où ce sont les victimes qu'on
change de poste qu'on change de site ou
qui s'octo excluent en quittant
l'entreprise il s'est d'ailleurs le
cabinet emprunt humaine qui a analysé
quatre cas du harcèlement sexuel en
association avec un laboratoire de
recherche de l'Université de Grenoble
Alpes c'est aussi d'ailleurs l'objet
d'un article de la revue des conditions
de travail numéro 13 de la nake où les
auteurs définissent très bien ce qu'est
un climat organisationnel sexiste avec
l'aide de trois critères
1 la banalisation des agissements
faisons sexistes ou sexuelle faisons
partie du métier et d'ailleurs le chef
cuisinier inculpé dans ce restaurant
explique très bien la prend conscience
de ses actes mais il dit moi-même en
tant qu'apprenti homme j'ai été victime
de tout ces actes quand j'étais dans mon
apprentissage je croyais que cela
faisait partie du travail et du métier
deuxième point c'est ce sentiment
d'impunité qui est associé d'ailleurs à
une inversion de la culpabilité au
niveau de la victime puisque le
les
personnes arrivent à montrer à la
victime que c'est finalement elle qui
est capable d'avoir mis une mini-jupe
d'avoir provoqué etc et le troisième
point très marquant également que
mentionne ses auteurs c'est le manque de
recadrage de la hiérarchie un la
hiérarchie ne voit pas ne sait pas et de
elle ne sait pas comment réagir et elle
ne réagit pas
alors en matière c'était le point sur la
prévention tertiaire je vais aller plus
rapidement sur la prévention secondaire
qui concerne les sensibilisations ou la
formation du personnel il nous en avons
réalisé un certain nombre quand comme de
plus en plus de consultants comme le
réseau des CIDFF comme la VFT dont on
parlait les sociologues en fait
sensibiliser former c'est bien mais
c'est insuffisant d'abord la majorité
des salariés n'en n'ont pas encore
bénéficié en France même si c'est une
obligation de l'employeur
les salariés en France ne distinguent
pas toujours pas
ne distingue toujours pas les situations
non sexistes du harcèlement sexuel du
harcèle du harcèlement sexuel des
agressions sexuelles et du viol même
s'il y a une des nuances à faire selon
l'âge or l'objectif est quand même de
former des gens capables de témoigner
même si comme l’ont dit les sociologues
ils ne font pas leur faire reposer toute
l'entière responsabilité
mais c'est un chercheur Benoît Dardenne
qui en 2021 souligne la nécessité d'être
sensibilisé aux violences pour pouvoir
déceler une situation de harcèlement
sexuel et donc décidé d'intervenir ou
non
mais les modules en ligne qui sont très
souvent proposés notamment pour les
managers ne permet pas de discuter or
pour pouvoir sensibiliser il faut
pouvoir discuter de ce sujet en intrant
entreprise il faut pouvoir lever le
tabou débattre des limites que les
équipes se donnent notamment en matière
de sexisme ordinaire de blague et c'est
pour cela que nous nous avons par
exemple à un acte produit un jeu sexisme
sans façon qui permet en trois quarts
d'heure de distinguer 6 niveaux de
sexisme quand je parle de sexisme cela
va du sexisme bienveillant jusqu'au viol
le contenu des formations de
sensibilisation animée par les
consultants portent de notre point de
vue aujourd'hui des approches beaucoup
trop comportementales il se permettent
par exemple de donner des conseils aux
femmes pour ne pas porter de mini-jupes
mais il est vrai que nous avons pu
constater aussi des actions qui sont
tout à fait intéressantes dans un
certain nombre
d'entreprises je pense par exemple à ce
bailleur social qui a tout d'abord formé
les membres du CODIR et l'argile puis
l'ensemble des comités de management qui
a réalisé également une campagne
d'affichage un peu choc pour rendre le
visible sur risques et pour interpeller
c'est également il a mis en place ce
bailleur social des petits groupes pour
libérer la parole et plus de 250
collaborateurs ont pu participer à des
actions de sensibilisation au VST ils
ont enfin réalisé une note de service
une newsletter en mentionnant les
référents les instances représentatives
le service RH le médecin du travail le
psychologue du travail avec toutes les
coordonnées
alors sur le troisième point
avant que je ne conclue sur la
prévention primaire les entreprises
mettent très rarement en place des
démarches collectives et organisations
elles ont restent toujours à une
approche individuelle et comportement
comportemental au lieu d'en faire un
sujet collectif qui implique donc la
direction des représentants du personnel
les encadrants les références et à ceux
et RH sont de très bons atouts mais leur
mission ne reste pas définie leur rôle
reste très fragile il manque de temps il
manque de moyens techniques
et comme l'on dit les sociologues les
entreprises abordent de très peu ce
sujet avec une approche systémique et
c'est un peu comme le même sujet que les
abus sexuels dans le rapport de la
science les entreprises très peu les cas
en aval pour en tirer des conséquences
pour l'amont sur les postes ou les
situations de travail à risque et au
final ce que l'on constate c'est qu'il
subsiste un très grand décalage entre
les intentions les engagements par
exemple la tolérance zéro l'Assomption
des auteurs et les actions menées et
finalement les actions ponctuelles
aujourd'hui ne produisent pas les
résultats escomptés il ne suffisent pas
pour considérer triste que de violence
comme sexistes et sexuelles comme un
véritable risque professionnel et
engager les actions de prévention
nécessaire mais à noter pour exemple
toujours que l'on retrouve dans la revue
des conditions de travail de la nacte
que ce bailleur social a inscrit le
risque de violence sexiste et sexuelle
dans le document unique d'évaluation des
risques à modifier son règlement
intérieur notamment sur le plan des
sanctions et a fait notamment une
information lors de l'accueil des
nouveaux embauchés je vais prendre
encore quelques minutes pour conclure
sous forme de recommandation
effectivement suite à tous ces constats
et ces difficultés la nacte considère
comme indispensable au-delà de la
sensibilisation et du traitement
individuel des cas d'apporter aux
entreprises
dirigeants représentant du personnel
référent CSE référent RH en priorité des
capacités d'action au niveau de
l'organisation et au niveau collectif
nous mettons en avant 4 recommandations
la première recommandation c'est qu'il y
a nécessité de renforcer l'articulation
du système de prévention aux trois
niveaux cette fameuse prévention
tertiaire pour qualifier l'effet dans
les situations avérée accompagner les
victimes sanctionner les auteurs en
mobilisant les entreprises pour qu'elle
fasse plus appel aux ressources externes
aux appuis externes pour traiter les
situations et pour mener les enquêtes
en prévention secondaire effectivement
que soit systématisé et rendu
obligatoire les formations
sensibilisation de l'onde des salariés
mais de manière spécifique des managers
des dirigeants et en prévention primaire
j'y reviendrai la deuxième
recommandation c'est d'associer
l'ensemble des acteurs et pour cela de
mieux définir les rôles émissions des
référentielso RH de leur donner plus de
moyens
et moyen de travail en lien avec les
directs présentant du personnel manager
et salarié c'est d'ailleurs l'objet du
projet de l'appel approché violon c'est
sexiste et sexuelle du ministère chargé
de l'égalité dont la nacte et L'Oréal
comme d'autres projets mais c'est aussi
d'associer en externe les acteurs de la
santé au travail et dans le cadre du
Plan Santé au Travail numéro 4 ce sont
les services de prévention et de santé
au travail qui sont ciblés sur ce sujet
de la prévention des violences mais
c'est aussi les carsats les inspections
du travail et puis bien sûr les
associations de protection des victimes
ou les CIDFF l'avait acheté les conseils
juridiques
et puis il s'agit en troisième
recommandation que l'entreprise
communique sur l'ensemble des actions
mises en oeuvre des chercheurs
chercheurs ont très bien mis en évidence
que des salariés ayant connaissance des
politiques organisationnels en matière
de prévention adoptent beaucoup plus
facilement des stratégies qu'on appelle
de faire face active et donc vont
signaler témoigner lorsque les travail
les milieux de travail ne montrent pas
leurs implications les salariés sont
moins inclinés enclins à témoigner et
puis le dernier point c'est pour nous en
tant qu'anac d'insister sur la
prévention primaire non pas pour réduire
à zéro le risque de violences sexistes
et sexuelles comme pour les risques
psychosociaux le risque zéro n'existe
pas mais de limiter de réduire les
facteurs du risque et cela passe par la
mise en place de cinq types d'action
réaliser un diagnostic des facteurs de
risque organisationnel suivant les
différents points que nous avons
mentionnés le mixité le degré
d'hiérarchie dans l'entreprise le type
de management les conditions d'emploi de
précarité les conditions de travail
deuxième point intégrer bien sûr le
risque de violence sexy sexuelle dans le
document unique d'évaluation des risques
c'est d'ailleurs un levier important sur
lequel on peut mobiliser les entreprises
car s'il y a un cas de harcèlement
sexuel dans leur entreprise ou
d'agression
elles peuvent être mises en défaut et
payer des indemnités si elles n'ont pas
intégré sur le risque dans leur document
unique mais d'une manière générale on le
sait et cela fait l'objet d'une audition
précédente que les risques
professionnels auxquels sont exposées
les femmes sont sous-estimées
quatrième point réaliser un diagnostic
des ressources en prévention primaire
secondaire tertiaire et puis c'est
construire des outils collectifs de
prévention en lien avec le CSE ou la
Commission ssct et cela se traduit par
des mesures organiques
intégration et tutorat des nouveaux et
particulièrement des personnes en statut
précaire et je le redis les stagiaires
les jeunes les personnes apprenties sont
les plus exposées
c'est tout ce qui est l'amélioration des
conditions de travail et d'emplois et là
je parle de choses très basiques des
vestiaires et des toilettes séparées
hommes femmes des cloisons et des portes
vitrées à mi-hauteur pour que les
personnes ne se retrouvent pas isolées
dans des bureaux c'est l'éclairage des
couloirs c'est les conditions de trajet
domicile travail quand il y a retour la
nuit c'est une prescription des tenues
et des scénographies de travail à
connotation sexuelle c'est un travail
sur la composition mixte des équipes ne
pas avoir une femme ou un homme seul
dans une équipe mono-saxe c'est une
répartition homme femme équilibrée des
activités limitant la division sexuée du
travail cela passe aussi par la
valorisation des activités et des postes
après dominance féminine et puis c'est
la mise en place d'espace de discussion
dans les collectifs de travail pour que
par exemple les assistantes comme nous
l'avons trop souvent rencontrés ne se
retrouvent pas isolé et n'osent pas
parler des avances sexuelles dont elles
sont l'objet et le dernier point c'est
de mettre en place une politique
égalitée professionnelle qui réduisent
effectivement les inégalités entre les
femmes et les hommes et qui consacrent
dans les accords ou plan d'entreprise
involi dédié à la prévention des
violences sexistes et sexuelles voilà
j'ai terminé
merci beaucoup madame
chaperte donc je vais immédiatement
passer la parole à Madame Rafael manière
de la CGT Merci à VOUS bonjour vous
m'entendez bien
merci pour cette invitation évidemment
la première chose qu'on se dit c'est que
ce sujet là des violences sexistes et
sexuelles sur les femmes au travail
c'est un sujet à part entière qui aurait
pu être traité dans une saisie à part
alors peut-être que vos prochains
travaux pourront partir sur cette
dimension
parce que si toutes les femmes ne vont
pas subir des TMS dans leur parcours
professionnel on sait que quasiment
toutes vont subir du sexisme et beaucoup
d'entre elles vont subir des violences
sexuelles dans leur parcours
professionnel entre harcèlement sexuel
agression et viol et que du coup on peut
le dire comme ça en fait les femmes au
travail elles sont finalement dans des
lieux où le danger règne et le danger
existe et quand on parle de violence
systémiques c'est de ça dont on parle
les chiffres donc moi je les redis pas
on les connaît ils ont été redis ils
sont insuffisants mais ils indiquent
l'ampleur du phénomène face auquel nous
sommes
toutes les femmes sont concernées sur
sur les violences sexistes et sexuelles
jeune vieille cadre ouvrière stagiaire
alternantes intérimaire quelle que soit
leur statuts elles vont subir dans leur
parcours professionnel
un moment donné elles vont se retrouver
dans une situation même ponctuelle ou
les relations vont être déséquilibrées
entre elles et un collègue ou des
collègues ou avec un chef ou avec des
clients ou bien entendu aussi avec des
conjoints ou des relations ponctuelles
amoureuses qui seront salariés dans le
même endroit qu'elle c'est vrai que
c'est un sujet qui est grave parce que
c'est une atteinte à la dignité des
femmes
quels sont ces violences au cœur du
processus de domination et que parler
d'égalité professionnelle et salariale
sans éradiquer en amont les violences
sexistes et sexuelles c'est un non sens
puisque la condition à la mise en place
de cette égalité même c'est de pouvoir
parler de ces violences
sexistes et sexuelles elles sont grave
aussi parce qu'elles remettent en cause
le droit fondamental des femmes à
travailler quelle est leur place au
travail dans ces situations là comment
elles gardent leur place au travail on
sait pour la majorité d'elle elles vont
pas garder leur place au travail elles
sont remises en cause dans ce droit là
c'est une remise en cause de leur
autonomie et de leur indépendance
financière évidemment et puis c'est
grave parce que les violences elles ont
un impact sur
la capacité des femmes à s'investir au
travail avec un manque d'estime de soi
qui va se prononcer une perte de
confiance de la culpabilité de la honte
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé j'ai laissé
dire ça j'ai laissé faire ça une fois
deux fois et après ben c'est un peu tard
j'aurais dû réagir avant
alors j'avais envie de poser la question
de on en est où au travail depuis mi
tout notamment puisque quand même cette
ce mouvement moment exceptionnel de
conscientisation des violences
masculines qui ont lieu au travail de
lieu à des débats publics à une
conscientisation qui est intéressante
qui bouscule tous les lieux de travail
et c'est très bien mais
[Musique]
et il manque une volonté politique forte
de changement qui suppose de bousculer
le patronat les employeurs et les
administrations publiques il faut il
faut discuter en fait or pour l'instant
on assiste en tout cas notre sens à des
postures de repli et de
ça les embête les violences arrivent
sous leurs yeux au travail mais qu'il
fallait les régler
alors comme vous pour nous les chiffres
qui existent et donc on en manque il y a
besoin de plus de visibilité pour aider
à la conscientisation de ce phénomène
social grave ils sont sous-estimés ils
sont décalifiés on parle de gestina
propriété de propos déplacés quand on
devrait plutôt parler de violence de
violences sexistes et quand je dis
violence ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
être traumatisé derrière il y a pas
besoin d'être traumatisé pour
s'autoriser à dire que ce qu'on a
entendu ou ce qui est dit relève d'une
violence simplement c'est pas normal
dans le cadre de relation au travail
et puis
j'ai indiqué ça par exemple
elles sont des qualifiées et
sous-estimées banaliser et minimiser on
a des situations de harcèlement sexuel à
la base d'une situation de violence qui
vont se transformer qui vont se
transformer en harcèlement moral à
caractère sexiste
quand là
il a tenté elle a dit non il va inverser
il va il va continuer la mise en place
de cette relation de domination en
mettant en cause ses compétences au
travail en mettant un système en place
qui va la décrédibiliser et là ça peut
être à un moment pour les femmes où ça
c'est pas supportable elles vont
supporter des choses en amont laisser
couler mais attaquer leur travail ça
c'est pas supportable et ça peut être
dans ces moments là aussi où elles vont
dire et dénoncer ce qui se passe pour
elle ces situations là elles sont pas si
parce qu'en fait il faut débusquer le
sexisme dans les dossiers de harcèlement
moral à caractère sexy soit c'est pas
simple mais c'est hyper intéressant
j'allais dire à faire en fait parce que
ça a du sens on comprend pourquoi il se
passe ce phénomène pour elle de
décrédibilisation sur son travail alors
qu'elle travaille bien mais finalement
c'est parce qu'il s'était passé quelque
chose en amont
alors il y a un autre angle mort c'est
les situations de violence conjugales
les femmes au travail
on a on a peu de chiffres enfin
moi j'en connais pas avec ces trois
dimensions possibles donc cette très
prégnant la première et c'est le
scénario le plus simple entre guillemets
c'est celui où ce sont des couples il y
a beaucoup de couples au travail qui se
font et qui se défont donc ces
situations de couple avec les deux
salariés sur le même travail
l'autre scénario c'est elles vont subir
des violences de couple elle elles sont
salariées monsieur et ailleurs mais les
femmes victimes de féminicides sont des
pour beaucoup des femmes salariées et
donc qu'est-ce qu'on sait d'elle de leur
situation au travail on en sait rien
enfin
ça sera intéressant de savoir ces femmes
qui qui sont mortes assassinées elles
étaient salariées dans quel lieu de
travail est-ce qu'il y avait une alerte
qui avait pu être posée pourquoi le lieu
de travail n'était pas un ressource un
lieu de ressources pour elle finalement
et comment on construit ce lieu de
ressources pour elle au travail c'est ça
la question qui est posée la troisième
possibilité sur les violences de couple
c'est très prégnant aussi ben c'est le
fait qu'il y ait des relations
ponctuelles dans les lieux même lieu de
travail entre les femmes et les hommes
et là aussi nous on a des scénarios
comme ça ou les représailles et le
harcèlement se met en place quand la
relation cesse mais ils sont c'est un
couple non cohabitant et pourtant on
peut parler de violence de couple même
s'ils vivent pas ensemble donc tous ces
scénarios là se présentent
aux délégués du personnel aux salariés
évidemment aux employeurs
avec nous cette impression qu'on
retrouve dans ce que vous disiez madame
chaper c'est la patate chaude pour les
employeurs quand il y a quand il y a une
alerte qui est posée je voulais vous
donner à voir parce que je suis oui
je travaille en Bourgogne Franche-Comté
à la vente et la SNCF donc à un accord
égalité pro avec un volet violent et
sexiste sexiste et sexuel et notamment
il y a une bonne pratique qui est
intéressante
ils ont un baromètre Ifop tous les ans
donc l'Ifop ça fait quatre ans travail
sur un échantillon à peu près de 2000
personnes 1025 femmes 992 hommes c'est à
ma connaissance la seule grande
entreprise à faire un travail comme ça
de visibilité sur les violences sexistes
et sexuelles pour la première année
l'année dernière elle a intégré la
dimension violence sexuelle sur notre
demande et donc ça donne sur il y a deux
il y a à la fois la perception du
sexisme le sexisme et la perception des
violences sexistes et sexuelles quelques
chiffres à partager avec vous parce que
dans cette bonne pratique ça permet
quand même de conscientiser moi j'ai des
collègues quand on leur a donné les
chiffres ils ont un petit peu cogité
dans leur tête parce que évidemment ils
ont du mal à se dire quand ils ont des
réflexions ils ont du mal à se dire qui
sont des gros machos que ça c'est du
harcèlement ou que s'il touche à cet
endroit là c'est une agression ils
savent pas et je ne le dis pas pour les
dédouaner mais on est vraiment dans
cette nécessité de donner à voir pour
faire grandir tout le monde sur ce qui
se passe sur le sexisme à la SNCF il y a
47% de femmes qui se disent victimes de
sexisme c'est c'est pas beaucoup comme
chiffres presque on pourrait dire
regarder chiffre qu'on peut connaître ça
montre ça monte chez les contrôleuses
oui c'est beaucoup mais
quand on c'est beaucoup mais en même
temps je suis sûr qu'il y en a plus que
47%
les clichés des contrôles ça monte à 67%
et sur les violences sexistes alors
sexuelles donc harcèlement sexuel
l'agression sexuelle viol et on n'a pas
le détail c'est 21% des femmes à la SNCF
et ça monte à 39% pour les contrôlesuses
donc ça permet à l'employeur de se dire
qu'il faut mettre un plan de prévention
particuliers sur ce personnel
normalement ça après c'est la
problématique de la mise en oeuvre des
plans de prévention puisque ça c'est
vraiment problématique dans tous les
lieux de travail et ce qui était
intéressant aussi dans ce baromètre
c'est le fait que les femmes se disent
elles sont comme par hasard elles sont
plus témoins que les hommes et ça c'est
important parce que quand on a des
enquêtes les témoins directs elles sont
rares par contre les témoins indirects
il y en a souvent et donc voilà on
observe finalement les femmes seraient
en tout cas dans ce baromètre plus
témoin peut-être avec un oeil plus un
guéri sur ce qui se passe autour d'elle
dans les relations de travail
alors ce qui était intéressant c'est que
elles sont de plus en plus à dénoncer ce
qui se passe pour elle au travail même
si
pour beaucoup elle ne disent rien et sur
la dimension violence conjugale bah là
aussi grande invisible ça a pas été pris
en compte dans le baromètre donc il y a
un gros travail à faire sur sur cette
dimension là il y a du désavancées quand
même depuis 2017 avec notamment 2018 la
mise en place des référentes et référent
harcèlement sexuels et agissements
sexistes dans les boîtes de plus de 250
c'est un dispositif insuffisant mais
c'est un début qui qui doit permettre
bon je reviendrai après sur les préco il
dans les autres avancées il y a une
obligation de négocier dans les branches
une obligation de traiter les vs dans
les documents uniques d'évaluation des
risques professionnels et ça ça c'est
pas fait pourtant ça c'est indispensable
pour établir qu'ils sont les facteurs de
risque dans tous les lieux de travail
il y a aussi
autre chose intéressante donc accord
égalité décliné dans les trois versants
de la fonction publique avec la création
donc des référents aussi violence
sexistes et sexuelles et puis bah on a
depuis 2019 la première loi mondiale
avec le i T et la convention 206 donc ça
c'est des c'est des tremplins pour aller
plus loin et il faut aller plus loin
nous ce qu'on observe dans les lieux de
travail c'est qu'il y a un besoin auprès
des employeurs toujours de comme pour
eux c'est la patate chaude on a besoin
de leur réexpliquer et d'expliquer aux
collègues aussi
il faut politiser le débat des violences
sexistes et sexuelles de travail de
rappeler que c'est pas une fatalité que
c'est un combat politique et qu'elle et
qu'elle ne résulte pas de problème
individuel on pointe évidemment la
responsabilité des employeurs qui est
énorme puisque ils ont la triple
obligation de prévention de protéger les
victimes de sanctions des agresseurs et
sur les trois dimensions on a beaucoup
de points de vigilance que je vais vous
citer après et puis en bataille beaucoup
en interne pour réexpliquer que ces
situations de violence on peut pas les
réduire à une vision de conflit
interpersonnel c'est pas un problème de
Monsieur et Madame qui s'entendent pas
il s'est passé autre chose à un moment
donné il y a une situation de domination
qui s'est mis en place une relation
déséquilibrée et c'est celle là qu'il
faut identifier pour permettre aux
ampleurs de comprendre que
les choses peuvent être remises à
l'endroit
plutôt que de parler de catégorie
sociale professionnelle plus ciblées ou
de lieu de travail je pense c'est plus
intéressant de réfléchir aux situations
vulnérabilité que subissent tout le
monde subit des situations de
vulnérabilité dans sa vie et donc c'est
assez moment là qui peut se passer
quelque chose dans les lieux de travail
donc ces situations de vulnérabilité et
puis
toujours cette nécessité d'identifier
les facteurs de risque pour pouvoir
anticiper les problèmes en fait les
prévenir
ne parle pas donc comment mettre en
place des dispositifs et une
communication la formation dans les
lieux de travail pour qu'elle s'autorise
à parler qu'elle dépasse justement
ce sentiment de honte à une culpabilité
qui va les les
tenir
comment les dispositifs dispositifs
pourraient être mis en place de
signalement pour donner confiance
justement si les procédures sont données
à avoir aux salariés quand elles sont
victimes de violence elles auront
peut-être plus la confiance pour poser
l'alerte que si elle ne savent pas ce
qui se passe quand elle parle et donc ça
ce sont des dispositifs à gagner
enfin qui devrait être mis en place dans
dans la fonction publique et au niveau
du privé on est en train de d'en gagner
certains dans certains accords égalité
pro
et c'est intéressant mais c'est du
Global pour que tout marche
la deuxième chose c'est sur la prise en
charge des femmes victimes bah là c'est
problématique c'est c'est la dimension
qu'il faut travailler de façon urgente
à l'avenir puisque
si dans la fonction publique il y a
quand même la protection fonctionnelle
qui existe qui pourrait être un levier
un vrai levier de protection pour les
femmes ce qu'on observe malheureusement
c'est que quand elle veulent le
mobiliser sur les situations de
violences sexistes sexuelles les
employeurs publics ne leur autorise pas
cela donc elles sont obligées d'aller
alors là pour celles qui vont ils sont
obligés d'aller au tribunal
administratif pour faire reconnaître ce
droit à la protection fonctionnelle qui
est hyper important parce que
parce que c'est l'autorisation à
une aide financière si elle décide
d'aller en justice par l'employeur mais
c'est aussi une aide financière pour les
soins
voilà la prise en charge psychologique
dont elles vont avoir besoin pour
continuer leur chemin et revenir au
travail et toute la bataille parce que
c'est une bataille quand on dénonce des
violences dans les lieux de travail
c'est une bataille qui s'engage avec
avec parfois l'employeur avec les
collègues
voilà la médecine du travail n'est pas
toujours disponible l'inspection du
travail c'est compliqué aussi donc il y
a un sentiment d'isolement qui est très
fort et qui est difficile donc
au niveau de des employeurs publics ça
devrait être exemplaire voilà on devrait
avoir déjà des procédures il y a des il
y a des circulaires il y a des accords
égalité pro qui devraient engager et
permettre une exemplarité des
comportements des employeurs publics et
malheureusement c'est pas ce qu'on
observe les femmes dans les
administrations publiques sont aussi
maltraités qu'ailleurs
mais peut-être juste sur la fin c'est
qu'elles vont moins sortir vite de
l'ampleur que celle qui n'ont pas cette
protection de l'emploi mais donc c'est
pas rien c'est très important mais pour
dire qu'il y a du travail sur l'amont
il y a des droits nouveaux à conquérir
il y a bon qui est des hobbies une
obligation de sécurité pour l'employeur
de formation de prévention mais aussi
des nouveaux droits et nous comme au
Canada ou en Nouvelle-Zélande qui a mis
en place des dispositifs de 10 jours de
congés supplémentaires pour les femmes
victimes du violence conjugales
c'est-à-dire qu'avec ces 10 jours les
employeurs
leur permettent de faire leur démarche
auprès auprès du juge auprès de la
police auprès de l'assistante sociale
auprès donc c'est dix jours en plus qui
existent et qui sont maintenant
officiels dans ces deux pays
et nous aussi on a besoin de trois
nouveaux pour les femmes qui en ont pas
que pas que celles qui subissent des
violences conjugales pour toutes celles
qui subissent les violences sexistes et
sexuelles de travail
parce qu'elles ont besoin de temps en
fait alors 10 jours ça peut paraître pas
beaucoup beaucoup pour certaines en tout
cas chaque situation est en différente
ça sera intéressant de voir une
flexibilité sur un droit nouveau à avoir
des jours pour s'occuper de soi pour
qu'elle puisse garder son emploi et
prendre soin d'elle parce que le
problème c'est que les personnes qui
sont victimes de violence sexuelles
c'est une effraction psychique et donc
derrière ça les choses ne vont pas
redevenir normal il y a besoin d'un
temps il y a la mémoire traumatique
elles vont avoir des flashs parfois
quand l'enquête est lancée
l'enquête s'est censé durer quelques
mois mais elle elle vont avoir des
flashs qui vont revenir encore des mois
et des mois après de ressasser ce qui a
pu se passer dans un lieu de travail qui
peut durer parfois des années ça peut
aussi être cool tous les scénarios sont
possibles mais
l'enquête quand elle est quand elle
quand elle a lieu l'employeur il attend
de la salarié qu'une fois que l'enquête
est faite que la sanction est posée
qu'elle revienne et que tout va bien et
on en parle plus mais ça se passe pas
comme ça
elle est victime de violence elle a
besoin de temps pour se reconstruire et
donc derrière on va tourner on peut
tourner en rond dans certaines
situations puisque pour savoir qu'elle
va être elle dans quelle place elle veut
elle veut l'être un nouveau travail
peut-être qu'elles auront besoin d'être
dans un autre atelier un autre espace un
autre lieu de travail donc pour cette
mutation géographique qui pourrait être
aussi un nouveau droit
pour qu'elle le réfléchisse
tranquillement faut d'abord qu'elles
aiment bien il faut d'abord qu'elle se
soit occupées de leur santé psychique et
donc ça ça demande du temps mais souvent
dans les lieux de travail il y a pas le
temps en fait on demande tu reviens là
il faut réfléchir tout de suite donc il
y a cette confrontation de de
temporalité je m'exprime pas bien je
suis désolé qui
ça frotte ça va pas il y a cette
temporalité qu'il faut prendre en compte
pour pour les victimes et ça dans les
lieux de travail avec les employeurs
c'est c'est pas acquis puisque toute
façon globalement ils sont pas formés
on a des points de vigilance aussi par
rapport aux procédures d'enquête alors
pourtant le code du travail est clair et
la boîte à outils est assez simple
puisque les définitions
ne demandent pas aux employeurs de
vérifier l'intention de l'agresseur de
nuire les employeurs ils ont pas à
vérifier ça ça c'est du pénal les
employeurs ils ont à vérifier nul ne
doit subir donc ils ont juste à vérifier
entre guillemets la situation de travail
a été malmenée à un moment donné avec
une relation déséquilibrée et voir de
domination et ça c'est le faisceau
d'indice c'est le récit de la victime
c'est la prise en compte des témoins
directs et indirect qui permet d'établir
si c'est passé quelque chose de normal
ou pas au travail et si l'enquête dit
qu'il s'est passé quelque chose
d'anormal au travail il y a pas besoin
de démontrer qu'il avait conscience de
ce qu'il faisait même si bien souvent
les agresseurs savent bien ce qu'ils
font quand même mais là il y a pas
besoin de chercher cette intentionnalité
de la prouver puisqu'en plus dans les
violences sexuelles ils reconnaissent
tous en continuant leurs phrases par
mais elle était d'accord donc
ça va être compliqué de démontrer qu'il
y avait une intention de lumière mais
l'employeur lui c'est simple la boîte à
outils et les carrés ils doivent agir
dès qu'il y a cette ce questionnement
sur la relation qui n'a pas été une
relation de travail et donc
pourtant nous ce qu'on observe c'est
beaucoup de tentations
d'agir tant qu'il y a pas de plainte les
ampleurs souvent ne veulent pas agir
alors qu'il y a pas d'obligation pour
les victimes d'aller au pénal donc il y
a cette vigilance là que nous on a il y
a la vigilance aussi par rapport aux
enquêtes c'est à dire comme le disait
madame chaper nous aussi on observe que
les employeurs
n'aime pas que les enquêtes soient
faites par les délégués du personnel via
la cssct si un droit d'alerte ou une
déclaration d'accident du travail c'est
un possibilité pour le CS via la cssct
d'enquêter donc d'avoir une enquête
conjointe ce qui nous semble nous
important parce que ça permet
l'impartialité et ça permet aussi donc
pour le coup nous on préconise pas que
les entreprises donnent les enquêtes à
l'externe auprès des cabinets qui et en
ce moment il y a bout des cabinets qui
se mettent en place et qui c'est cher
veut dire toutes les entreprises elles
auront pas 10000 euros à donner un
cabinet pour enquêter pendant deux mois
donc la question se pose de savoir faire
le travail en interne donc comment on se
ferme on se forme et les enquêtes
conjointes via la cscct c'est vraiment
un moment de formation c'est peut-être
bête de le dire comme ça mais c'est
comme ça on va les former avant mais
quand il y a une enquête c'est aussi un
moment réfléchit ensemble on écoute la
victime les témoins le mise en cause on
va entendre de mise en cause et c'est
aussi comme ça qu'on grandit et qu'on et
qui a de la pédagogie qui se met en
place en fait dans le lieu de travail
parce que le but c'est de détailler le
sujet il est trop souvent mis sous le
sous le tabi le tapis avec des
employeurs ne sachant pas par quel bout
commencer donc ils ont besoin
d'accompagnement voilà il faut aussi
déstructures qui sachent les accompagner
mais il faut pas enlever la
responsabilité
enfin évidemment pas aux employeurs mais
c'est bien d'emmener les représentants
du personnel aussi dans ses capacités
d'enquêtes parce que d'abord en plus
c'est eux souvent qui font les droits
d'alerte on a observé nous une
difficulté à qualifier les employeurs
ils veulent pas qualifier or si on
qualifie pas on donne pas on rend pas
visible la nature des violences qui ont
eu lieu et nous on s'est rendu compte
que les victimes souvent ne savent pas
faire la différence entre harcèlement
sexuel et une agression sexuelle donc il
faut qualifier ce qui s'est passé on n'a
pas besoin d'être juges pour dire
que toucher les hanches les épaules et
le ventes ça relève du harcèlement
sexuel ce sont des attouchements mais
les cuisses et les fesses et les seins
et les seins c'est une agression
sexuelle donc il y a besoin de toujours
dans cette
en fait nécessité de pédagogie et de
formation mais qui est en continu
évidemment il doit y avoir la prévention
en amont tout ce que disait madame
chaper à toutes les strates mais quand
il y a des dossiers il y a aussi dans le
continuum de la vie d'un collectif de
travail en fait
quand il y a un signalement ça devrait
servir à ce que tout le monde sorte plus
grand de ce qui s'est passé plutôt que
de se retrouver avec des collectifs de
travail qui vont être clivés ou derrière
la reprise du travail va être très
compliquée pour la victime parce que les
choses ne vont pas être dites et
travailler avec elle et donc elle elle
va subir la double peine d'avoir subi à
la fois des violences et de ne pas
retrouver sa place au travail
voilà sur les enquêtes la mise à pied
conservatoire du mise en cause on a
remarqué que c'était aussi difficile
c'est à dire c'est pris comme une
sanction alors que ça ne l'est pas c'est
un moment au contraire ça permet de
lever la pression sur un lieu de travail
le la personne mise en cause est mise à
pied c'est pas une sanction la victime
peut l'être aussi si elle a besoin de
temps et d'être chez elle mais la
question pour les mises en cause c'est
vraiment primordiale et c'est pas du
tout spontané dans les mises en place de
protection des employeurs enfin le rôle
des référents référentes
ils sont pas inclus dans les dans les
enquêtes voilà il y a un dispositif qui
est intéressant mais ça ça
par peur en fait des employeurs de voilà
de d'impliquer comme si d'impliquer des
référents ou des membres du CSE était un
frein à la résolution de du problème
j'ai peut-être déjà trop parlé je ne
sais pas j'ai encore des choses à dire
je crois mais
oui vous dire parce que ce qui était
intéressant quand même c'est que les
organisations syndicales sur cette
thématique elles sont
elles sont elles sont elles sont soudées
et il y a eu un courrier faible puisque
vous il y avait quand même la question
des préconisations un courrier qui a été
fait de toutes les organisations
syndicales que je vous passerai en
novembre pour alerter la première
ministre donc
toutes les organisations syndicales un
revenaient sur les problématiques de
mise en place de de prévention des
enquêtes de la prise en compte des
victimes des problèmes de financement
des manques de personnel dédiés pour
pour régler et assez opérationnels pour
régler les problèmes de violence sexy
sexuelle et donc il y a des propositions
sur quatre dimensions la première les
organisations demandent une table ronde
multilatérale pour réaliser des bilans
en fait des dispositifs de 2018
c'est-à-dire les références c'est super
mais ça marche pas donc pourquoi en ce
moment ça se négocie entreprise par
entreprise quand on peut avoir des
accords où on gagne un référent plus par
lieu de travail avec un portable un
bureau une formation en plus alors quand
ça va être la VFT c'est encore mieux
mais en tout cas avec des associations
bien dédiées donc il faut questionner ce
dispositif des référents et lui donner
beaucoup plus d'ampleur et de deux
moyens
il y a un bilan à faire sur de la
négociation collective sur les violences
sexistes sexuelles notamment dans les
branches parce que il devait négocier
mais ont-elles négocier quelle
visibilité quel retour
un bilan quantitatif et qualitatif sur
la mise en place dans la fonction
publique des cellules d'écoute et des
dispositifs d'accompagnement des
victimes
il se passe des choses intéressantes
dans la fonction publique mais et ça
devrait être beaucoup plus
sécurisant pour les femmes de travailler
à cet endroit là mais pourquoi ça ne
l'est pas un bilan qualitatif et
quantitatif des dispositifs de
prévention existants voilà
et puis il y avait une demande d'une
publication dans la fonction publique de
guide des outils statutaires pour lutter
contre les violences sexistes et ça ça a
été fait au mois de novembre maintenant
le problème qu'il y a c'est sa mise en
oeuvre
en deuxième point on demande alors on
propose
les organisations syndicales proposent
par exemple que le Haut Conseil à
l'égalité
produise un baromètre annuel pour
évaluer le ressenti des salariés et des
agents sur les violences sexistes et
sexuelles au travail pour donner des
indications objectives sur l'état de la
prise en compte du sujet
donc ça c'est une proposition
sur les recommandations nous dans le
privé et le public donc faire de la
prévention un sujet obligatoire de
négociation
étant donné que ce n'est pas fait on
propose sous peine de sanction pour les
employeurs
mettre en place une obligation de
formation de tous les managers RH
représentants du personnel
voilà puisque ça rejoint les
recommandations
de vous mesdames
mettre en place une obligation de
sensibilisation annuelle sur les
violences sexistes sexuelles organisées
sur le temps de travail et les lieux de
travail
en quatrième point donc il y a la
question de sécuriser l'emploi et la
carrière des victimes de violence
qu'elles aient ou non un lien avec le
travail pour faire lien avec les
violences conjugales alors le voilà les
premières
revendications proposition c'est nouveau
droit dont je vous parlais donc avec des
nouveaux jours notamment qui pourraient
du nombre de 10 pour pour leur garantir
du temps pour faire leur démarche
interdire le licenciement comme c'est le
cas pour les victimes de violences au
travail puisque on observe beaucoup la
double peine pour les femmes
victimes de violence renforcer les
possibilités d'action des référentes
harcèlement sexuels donc
je reviens pas et puis dans le privé
plus spécifiquement élargir les
prérogatives les moyens et la formation
des conseillers du salarié au
harcèlement sexuel pour permettre aux
salariés des entreprises sans IRP sans
institution représentative du personnel
d'être quand même accompagné face à
l'employeur
puisque pour l'instant les conseillers
du salarié peuvent être mobilisés sur
des problématiques de licenciement mais
pas de harcèlement sexuel donc on a des
nouveaux des nouvelles prérogatives à
penser pour ne pas laisser seuls les
femmes et puis augmenter le nombre et la
formation des inspections inspectrices
du travail voilà ça c'était les
recommandations merci merci beaucoup
madame j'avais du mal à vous arrêter
puisque l'intervenant de précédente
avait largement multiplié son temps par
deux donc ça veut je me voyais en
difficulté pour vous dire STOP merci à
vous quatre pour ces présentations
extrêmement précises et complémentaires
je vais me tourner vers les les
rapporteurs si elles souhaitent vous
poser des questions ou si la
présentation à
finalement a répondu oui la madame la
rapporteur Laurence Rossignol
merci à vous quatre pour vos propos
passionnants exhaustifs j'avais quelques
questions la première mais peut-être ça
n'existe pas sur le problème de notre
frénés de notre appétit immense de
statistiques de croisement voilà sur les
les effets sur la santé
de nombreux arrêts maladie
des maladies psychologiques troubles
psychologiques bref tous les indicateurs
statistiques qu'on peut avoir
consommation de psychotropes entre le
fait d'avoir subi des violences
sexistes et sexuelles enfin notre sujet
c'est la santé des femmes on a bien
conscience que dans le maintien de
harcèlement il y a aussi des hommes
victimes de harcèlement mais bon d'un
sujet on s'y tient est-ce qu'on est-ce
que vous avez quelque chose à nous
fournir la nature ça existe pas ça
existe pas
la deuxième question
concerne plutôt
pour vous Madame manière ce que vous
avez évoqué le fait qu'il est que des
femmes avaient été obligé d'aller au
travail administratif pour obtenir leur
protection fonctionnelle
comment il faudrait réformer
l'accès à la protection fonctionnelle
pour leur épargner d'aller au tribunal
administratif puisque de toute façon les
malheureuses vont rentrer dans un
abominable tunnel
judiciaire administrates administratifs
administratif tribunaux pénal
prud'hommes enfin bref si on peut leur
en épargner et enfin Evène troisième
remarque c'est plus une remarque une
question
quand vous avez dit que était plus
exposé c'est vous était plus exposé
aux violences au travail en
psychologique au travail les précaires
je comprends
célibataire et mère monoparentales ça ça
m'a attiré l'oreille si j'ose dire ce
qui veut dire qu'en fait qu'une femme
dotée d'un homme
serait protégé par le fait qu'il existe
un homme à l'extérieur comment vous
qu'est-ce que vous avez comme
explication à nous fournir je sais que
vous êtes des scientifiques donc si vous
n'avez pas d'explication vous n'allez
pas faire uniquement de l'intuition mais
est-ce que vous en avez une là dessus
alors est-ce qu'on prend toutes les
questions peut-être c'est peut-être plus
efficace donc qui souhaitent parmi les
rapporteurs interpellés interrogés lance
Cohen oui bonjour mesdames et merci
beaucoup effectivement vos propos ont
balayer
beaucoup de choses
moi c'est sur deux ou trois points où
j'aimerais avoir des éclaircissements et
c'est vrai que
en prolongement d'ailleurs des
questionnements de ma collègue Laurence
Laurence Rossignol
ce qui me semble intéressant et j'ai pas
je l'ai pas entendu c'est que souvent
quand il existe des affaires donc de
violences sexuelles et sexistes les
entreprises n'aiment pas du tout
que ce soit rendu visible
et donc la publicité si je puis dire je
sais pas comment appeler ça mais oui la
publicité de des faits qui se produisent
et très mal venue pour les entreprises
et ce que je me disais c'est est-ce que
vous avez
sur ce sujet là c'est à dire rendre
compte en fait et et
informer
des violences sexuelles et sexistes dans
telle ou telle entreprise pourrait les
rendre visibles c'est à dire que comme
vous l'avez dit enfin je crois que vous
l'avez tout dit les violences sexuelles
et sexistes sont mises sur le tapis
elles sont invisibilisées le plus
possible
ça rend service aux agresseurs mais pour
les femmes pour les femmes victimes ça
n'est pas évidemment pour les aider donc
le fait de rendre
visible de publier
sous forme de statistiques ou carrément
parce que je me souviens par exemple
quand il y avait eu des procès notamment
pense à une banque d'ailleurs qui avait
où on avait on avait rendu public les
avocats avaient rendu public
les choses l'entre enfin la banque avait
été très mal à l'aise mais je veux dire
que ça peut concourir à justement
visibilité les violences donc est-ce que
vous avez des éléments là-dessus ça
c'est mon premier ma première question
la deuxième question est et je trouve
que Raphaël manières
à la BMI en exergue c'est effectivement
cet angle mort au niveau des violences
conjugales
c'est à dire que les violences
conjugales ont ces pertinemment qu'elles
ont des répercussions terribles sur la
santé mentale et physique des femmes
mais donc ces femmes sont pour la
majorité d'entre elles des salariés et
comment on peut
enfin je veux dire arriver à exercer son
activité quand on subit des violences
sexuelles sexuelles et sexy dans son
couple et là c'est totalement
mis sous le boisseau et je voudrais
savoir quel
préconisations qu'elle recommandations
vous avez à partager avec nous pour
essayer justement de de faire reculer
cette cet angle mort et la dernière la
dernière question remarque c'est que moi
je suis très frappée par le fait que
d'une manière générale et c'est vrai
pour les vs
d'une manière générale
les gouvernements successifs les
pouvoirs publics ne font
très rarement le bilan des soit des
expériences qui sont menées soit des
politiques qui sont mises en place on
évalue pas ou peu les politiques qui
sont mises en place et je trouve que
dans le domaine donc des violences
sexuelles et sexistes c'est majeur parce
que justement il faudrait qu'on puisse
évaluer pour que les bonnes pratiques
soient partagées et soit
donc instauré dans toutes les
entreprises et je pense à l'expérience
par exemple la SNCF je ne la connaissais
pas enfin c'est le baromètre là c'est
intéressant pourquoi ça n'est pas élargi
à l'ensemble au moins des entreprises
publiques voilà mes trois questions
merci Annick rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames pour vos exposés très fournis
très documentés
moi je voudrais vous poser une question
est-ce que dans vos statistiques est-ce
que
Madame manière dans la dans la les cas
que vous avez rencontrées ou est-ce que
vous nous avez dit Madame manière que
toutes les toutes les femmes quel que
soit l'âge quel que soit la situation
rencontrer au moins une fois dans leur
vie ces situations de violence de
sexisme
la délégation des droits aux femmes
l'année dernière à sortir un rapport
chaud sur la pornographie et notamment
sur l'accès qu'avait les jeunes à ces
sites pornos puisqu'on avait cité des
chiffres des enfants de 15 ans de 9 ans
qui avait librement accès à ces sites et
qui avait finalement une vision déformée
et de la sexualité des rapports plus
tard qui pourraient avoir avec les
femmes est-ce que il y a pas bien
longtemps j'ai entendu aussi une
statistique qui disait que les jeunes
les jeunes hommes étaient presque plus
violent avec les femmes que je dirais à
notre génération alors est-ce que vous
pensez que finalement tout ce qu'on
tousse qu'on voit tout ce qui est publié
peut peut jouer est-ce que vous pensez
que le fait qu'il n'y ait plus dans les
écoles puisqu'il y a je crois que 13%
des écoles dans lesquelles il y a un
enseignement sur la vie affective
sexuelle est-ce que il faudrait pas
aussi à ce niveau là développer j'allais
dire l'éducation
où le respect entre les hommes les
femmes dans les deux sens
pour reprendre les propos de ma collègue
Laurence cohel quand elle parle de
bonnes pratiques alors est-ce que ça
pourrait être pour vous aussi un axe
dans la prévention puisque c'est aussi
je pense cet axe là qu'il faut viser
merci
merci beaucoup et la dernière rapporteur
à parler ce matin Marie guéricher merci
mesdames pour pour vos présentations moi
je vais d'abord rebondir sur une
interrogation de Laurence Rossignol
puisqu'on parlait des familles
monoparentales etc madame delà je sais
que vous êtes intéressé notamment aux
femmes issues de la entre guillemets de
la classe dites populaires par rapport à
leur à leurs conditions de vie de
travail et d'emploi qui pour vous reste
aussi un des angle mort aujourd'hui de
la prise en compte de la santé des
femmes au travail donc je pense que ça
rejoint
l'interrogation de ma collègue donc si
vous pouviez développer un petit peu
parce qu'on a parlé de Me Too mais on a
mis tout et les dénonciations qu'il y a
eu à ma connaissance concerne une
certaine catégorie professionnelle et et
de femmes issues d'un certain milieu on
va dire donc oui donc je pense que ça ça
pourrait être aussi intéressante puisque
dans les questions que qu'a poser la
Présidente il y avait des questions qui
concernait certains certains secteurs
professionnels sont-ils plus concernés
que d'autres et
il me semble évident sans avoir la
science infuse que pour certains métiers
précaires on va dire ou de première
ligne comme cela souvent été dit ces
derniers temps
l'impact est quand même plus difficile
pour dénoncer des actes des actes
sexistes ou sexuels il me semble
mesdames tout à l'heure que ça avait dit
que le monde du travail pouvait aller
ressources et à contrario il me semble
avoir entendu que c'était difficile que
ce soit un lieu ressources donc si vous
pouviez si vous pouviez c'est ça si vous
pouviez un peu l'évoquer parce que
hormis madame on a peu parlé de des
médecins du travail et pour les avoir
pour en avoir auditionné une récemment
on sait que c'est quand même primordial
et puis j'avais noté alors tout à
l'heure je ne sais plus qui les
agresseurs savent ce qu'ils font
les agresseurs savent ce qu'ils font et
en même temps je parlerai au niveau
générationnel de ces agresseurs parce
que à chaque heure je vous avais parlé
tout à l'heure du côté paternalisme qui
englobe tellement de de choses qui m'est
un petit peu le couvercle sur sur
la casser la cocotte-minute plutôt j'ai
pas et
en même temps est-ce que vous pensez
vraiment que c'est générationnel et ce
que le comportement aujourd'hui de ces
agressions sexistes et sexuelles sont
générationnel ou ou alors est-ce
qu'elles sont elles sont sous couvertes
de certaines professions et puis pour
conclure j'ai noté ce qu'on retrouve
dans beaucoup de nos
auditions que l'on fait aujourd'hui
concernant la santé des femmes au
travail il y a quand même des mots qui
ressortent angle mort invisibilité déni
tabou comment on s'en sort merci merci
mesdames les rapporteurs je vais
demander à nos invités ce matin de faire
des réponses courtes consiste puisque
vous êtes obligé de partir au milieu de
vos réponses que je préside à 10h30 ce
genre de truc on peut pas du tout donc
Madame la vice-présidente et rapporteur
Laurence Rossignol sera excusée bien
entendu puisque la séance démarre à
10h30 et d'ailleurs il y a d'autres
auditions de commission d'enquête aussi
donc si vous pouvez mesdames
faire court mais en répondre quand même
à mesdames les rapporteurs et de toute
façon dans tous les cas vous pourrez
nous envoyer des compléments
d'information par mail si vous le
souhaitez
je vous laisse peut-être démarrer
puisque vous étiez les derniers
interpellés et peut-être démarrer
puisque la question faisait écho à celle
de la rapporteur Laurence Rossignol
celle de Marie-Pierre Richer comme ça au
moins la rapporteur entendra votre
réponse c'est d'autant plus par la
première question pour vous permettre
d'entendre la réponse vous posiez la
question des effets sur la santé et des
mesures donc Pauline l'a dit on a plus
de chiffres beaucoup plus de chiffres et
le problème c'est plus leur lisibilité
et leur compatibilité savoir comment s'y
retrouver que de ne pas avoir de
chiffres un des phénomènes on peut
peut-être répondre moi sur événement de
vie et santé que j'ai coordonné pour le
ministère de la Santé toi sur le virage
un des phénomènes qui est apparu dans
cette enquête donc avait été commandée
par le cabinet de Jean-François Mattei
et reçu par Roselyne Bachelot dans cette
enquête événement de vie et santé
c'était que les conséquences sur la
santé alors étonnamment quand on quand
on fabrique les chiffres et quand on est
dans les statistiques sur la santé
physique n'apparaissent pas très
facilement beaucoup de personnes que
l'on voit très victimes très chargées de
ne déclare pas des conséquences
physiques il y a véritablement des
conséquences sur la santé très marquées
sur les sur la santé mentale et moins
sur les conséquences physiques quand il
y a un ensemble de caractéristiques et
donc là je réponds aussi à votre
deuxième
réponse c'est à dire que ce sont des
individus sociaux alors on essaie de
capturer ce qui se passe dans le travail
à la maison dans les espaces publics
mais la personne elle est plus ou moins
âgée en situation monovante parentale ou
pas et c'est le contexte de l'ensemble
des caractéristiques sociales c'est ce
qu'on voit apparaître dans ces enquêtes
qui fait que des violences entraînent
des conséquences sur la santé mentale
d'abord mais physique aussi avec un
ensemble de facteurs de vulnérabilité
alors ça c'est difficile à attraper et
une des grandes
[Musique]
un des grands défis des enquêtes depuis
l'envers en passant par événement de vie
et santé et en allant jusqu'à virage ça
a été justement par rapport à des
variables statistiques habituellement
observées professionnelles sociaux
professionnels le revenu etc par rapport
à ces variables qui ne sont pas
forcément opérantes à elle seule pour
identifier qui est victime de voir
comment elle se combine et donc là
l'analyse que l'analyse féministe
revendique comme intersectionnelle est
vraiment intéressantes de voir que ce
sont des profils de cumul de difficultés
sociales qui arrivent avec des
situations violences
madame manière parlait de moments de
vulnérabilité ou des personnes cumulent
ces problèmes de revenus d'emploi etc
pour virage peut-être donc juste pour
dire effectivement donc l'enquête virage
a aussi un chapitre consacré à la
question de la santé et des effets des
violences de genre sur la santé donc je
vous vois il est en ligne vous pourrez
le voilà le consulter effectivement ça
objective certains des effets notamment
psychiques en termes de dépression
longue etc mais aussi certains facteur
qu'on pourrait envisager comme des
facteurs protecteurs notamment le niveau
de diplôme et l'environnement social est
encore une fois donc il y a pas d'effets
il y a pas de de
réactions type en fait au violence
puisque il y a un ensemble aussi de
facteurs qui peuvent protéger les femmes
victimes de
répercussions à long terme de ces
violences tu finis sur tes questions et
puis je reprends après alors sur les
questions que vous avez posées sur
d'autres questions
sur l'invisibilité des violences
conjugales peut-être madame Cohen
la négation la délégation le secrétariat
des femmes a commandé une étude à
laquelle j'ai participé il y a quelques
années sur le chiffrage du coup des
violences conjugales et des conséquences
au moment de la loi des conséquences sur
les enfants
enfants et famille et donc j'ai repris
des chiffres exacts dans le montant
global du coup les violences conjugales
la violence dans le couple dans les
relations de couple c'était 3 milliards
600 millions et les arrêts de travail
liés à ces violences pour les femmes
représentent 108 millions environ
euh en 2016 ou 2014 les chiffres je
vérifiais donc sur l'actualité des
chiffres et pour les femmes et pour les
hommes c'était 3 millions 400
000 à peu près donc 508 millions pour
les femmes en termes d'arrêt de travail
le plus de chiffrage et là discuter de
chiffrage du coût des vidence conjugales
en termes de pertes de gains de travail
c'est-à-dire de perdre de productivité
perte de revenus etc c'est toujours à
double tranchant aussi puisque si on
signale aux employeurs que les personnes
qui vont être à
tendance de d'arrêt de travail répété
peuvent être effectivement des personnes
qui vont être mon productives ça peut
être évidemment un double tranchant sur
la fragilité vis-à-vis de l'employeur
donc ces situations là elles sont
particulièrement sensibles pour savoir
comment protéger ces personnes donc
Madame manière parlait de voilà 10 jours
de congés de plus
au contraire on a le droit du travail
protège une personne malade ne peut pas
être licenciée donc ces personnes là
devrait être particulièrement on devrait
être attentive à leur situation pour que
ces arrêts de travail à répétition
puisqu'on voit que 108 millions c'est
quand même beaucoup
bénéficier d'une protection particulière
sur les jeux sur pour Madame Jacques
mais je prends rapidement donc du coup
les vous parliez des
questions que vous aviez c'était est-ce
que les jeunes hommes sont peut-être
presque plus violents vous avez dit donc
la question qu'on se pose toujours
voilà donc la question qu'on se pose
toujours sur l'âge et la violence alors
dans les enquêtes il y a une façon très
simple de répondre ou très simple ou
toujours mystérieuse malgré tout de
répondre à cette question c'est que
depuis les années 60 ou les enquêtes de
victimisation ont commencé à être
réalisés aux États-Unis les jeunes
générations déclarent toujours plus de
violences agit et suivies c'est à dire
qu'on a toujours eu l'impression depuis
qu'on mesure ce phénomène que les jeunes
sont les jeunes sont toujours plus
violents et dans les enquêtes on sait si
on obtient des résultats dans un cas
statistique si on obtient des résultats
différents on sait que on a quelque
chose tout à fait étrange on sait que
très très régulièrement on va trouver
quelque chose qui est qu'à la fois en
termes de violence agit déclarée ce
qu'on relève très peu dans la
statistique en France d'autres pays le
fondamentage que nous mais aussi en
termes de violences subies les jeunes
déclarent plus violents et donc ça on
l'explique difficilement mais par des
effets combinés alors est-ce qu'il y a
un effet de génération ben non parce que
sinon quand ils arrivent à 50 ans
pourquoi ils se mettrai à déclarer moins
de violence donc c'est pas des
générations qui sont violentes alors il
y a certainement un effet de génération
qui est la perception de la violence
donc il déclare aussi plus de violences
parce qu'ils ont un rapport à la
violence qui est peut-être différent
d'une autre enfin d'une autre et de ceux
qui ont avancé en âge il y a un effet
d'âge c'est-à-dire qu'il y a on l'a dit
au travail là je jeûne et
particulièrement dans certains métiers
dans une enquête à laquelle j'ai
participé sur les violences dans la
profession d'avocat par exemple les
jeunes avocats sont extrêmement
extrêmement exposés à des dénigrements
des violences sexistes avec des
différences hommes femmes absolument
gigantesques donc là il y a un effet
d'âge d'exposition à des comportements
des tensions et des violences et il y a
aussi un effet de mémoire c'est à dire
que quand on vieillit on fait malgré
tout même quand les événements ont été
très durs très difficiles à entraîner
tout un tas de conséquences on ne
déclare plus on oublie entre guillemets
alors ça dire on sélectionne
c'est-à-dire on t en partie et on oublie
véritablement aussi où on ne reconnaît
plus comme violent des événements qu'on
aurait qu'on avait aussi vécu comme
violent éventuellement quand on était
plus jeune
sur les catégories sur meeto peut-être
que tu reprends les catégories sociales
effectivement c'est une question aussi
madame Richer
et le lieu de travail ressources et on
va peut-être laisser répondre la nacre
et la CGT sur le lieu de travail
ressources et oui
j'ai quelques éléments quand même à Port
sur la question de la monoparie oui je
fais cours je fais quoi sur la question
de la monoparie
la monoparlan parentalité mais c'est que
c'est un facteur de précarité pour les
femmes et un facteur aussi de
subordination de vulgaire habilités
c'est-à-dire que ça fait effectivement
partie de ces configurations ou des
violences peuvent exercer par le biais
de d'une multitude de facteurs donc on
peut parler d'intersectionnalité
effectivement mais c'est des facteurs
sociaux des facteurs de genre etc il a
besoin
de mes travaux sur les femmes de classe
populaire madame ce que vous m'avez
interpellé à ce propos il s'agissait
plutôt de travaux sur les politiques
publiques qui ciblent certaines femmes
aux dépend d'autres et notamment il
s'agissait de retour sur des travaux de
collecte sur les politiques d'égalité
professionnelle qui tendent justement à
cibler les femmes de classe supérieure
de classe moyenne et supérieure plutôt
que les femmes de classe populaire et
mes collègues donc parlent de la notion
d'égalité élitiste à cet endroit qui de
fait rendent invisible aussi les
conditions de vie d'emploi et de travail
des femmes de classe populaire donc qui
sont marquées par des horaires atypiques
le temps partiel des salaires faible etc
mais c'est les conditions là doivent
être nécessairement prises en compte
justement puisque c'est un facteur de
vulnérabilité et ces femmes là sont
sortes d'une certaine façon des radars
des pouvoirs publics
notamment dans le traitement des luttes
contre les violences et l'égalité
professionnelle
sur la question de l'angle mort des
violences conjugales effectivement donc
ce qui est intéressant c'est que en
faisant encore une fois un retour sur
l'action publique qui s'est développé
depuis les années 2000 sur les violences
faites aux femmes les violences
masculines en fin de compte les
violences conjugales elles tendent à
capter l'attention publique puisque
c'est le plus gros des lois et des
politiques publiques en fait ce qui se
sont qui s'est centrées sur ce type de
violence par contre effectivement quand
il s'agit de certaines sphères et
notamment du travail et bien là ça sort
de c'est ça devient invisible au sens où
les conséquences de sa violence
deviennent invisibles et pour les femmes
en tant que sal Arié
[Musique]